how does the screenwriter know that they
have a bad idea there aren't any bad
ideas no again King's Speech there's no
worse idea than that Sopranos is a if
you just described it it's ridiculous
and certainly Breaking Bad we've already
talked about that the there are only bad
stories and those are stories that where
one thing doesn't really follow another
were--it where where where they not
integrated that is to say where
everything that happens there's not
palpably measurably identifiably move
the story forward that's all you have to
do but that's a that's a tall order okay
so it's not just an idea of being bad or
good because even a good idea what
sounds great in theory if the character
which is the focus of the story this is
what moves the story along that is the
story right the characters characters
what they do what they say that is who
they are that is the characters and it's
also the story so let's say we have
story a and story B so story a is what
sounds great in theory it's a
fascinating film coming of age
against all odds and then Story B which
is very vanilla may be middle class cult
a sac neighborhood insurance salesman
with you know no real quirks just very
basic well you know the greatest
American play is written about a you
know the protagonist is a joint salesman
salesman with Loman is an insurance
salesman About Schmidt which is written
and directed by our own Alexander Payne
a student here former student of mine
you know somebody we're really proud of
here at UCLA it's a great well I think
that's a fabulous movie I think it's
Nicholson's best work and it's not sure
in salesmen how about this for a movie
an insurance salesman retires you're
asking me you know what what's good it
was a bit early I'm saying that that
there are no banner there the good news
is there are no bad ideas why is that
good news because well I can't have a
bad idea this the bad news is it doesn't
matter it's not about ideas this is not
about
ideas ideas are not important in
dramatic narratives that's a mouthful to
say and gets me a lot of criticism I was
at a scholarly conference I was telling
you that I rarely go to scholarly
conferences I go to a lot of writers
conferences but it was that an academic
scholarly conference and someone said at
a writing panel this was out of town
this was up in Montana he said you know
the problem with your program at UCLA I
really wanted to hear the rest of this
is that we encourage writers to write
screenplays that are get ready now
because I've memorized this too deeply
encoded into the dominant narrative mode
I'll say it again we encourage writers
to write scream it was in a to deeply
encoded into the dominant narrative mode
as I looked at myself what in the world
and then I realized narrative is usually
what they say when they mean story I
heard myself say to him because I was
very good I said you you means story and
he said yes yes and I said to him guilty
you're right that's us we we're story
hardliners we think it's all about story
he said what we should be doing is is
inculcating into new writers the the
respect for the value of ideas sounds
great doesn't it but I was saying well
I'm so sorry but we think ideas are
worthless and useless again it doesn't
go over very well but it's the truth any
real writer who who's a serious writer
who has any kind of success will will
tell you it's not about the idea
sometimes when they say oh I got a great
idea MA they really believe that it is a
great idea it's not just an idea in fact
it's a story that's all worked out for
example with King's Speech it's not just
a guy who stutters and hires a speech
therapist it's the King of England its
World War two you know what all of this
as when you start to describe it it's no
longer just the idea
now you're telling the story I'm gonna
say it again it's so obvious it's that
it's it's hard to see sometimes things
are so obvious you just can't see them
and again here it is it's all about
story that's all it's about it's about
telling a good story
taking boyhood again again I loved it
but you said it was it was good but it
didn't really move you maybe what would
you have done with it within those three
hours I would have trimmed I'm gonna
taken an hour out of it oh I think
there's a good movie in there somewhere
but I would have cut it I mean again
it's two hours and 45 minutes it's don't
excuse for it
he's his own worst enemy by the way
Linklater made one of the my favorite
movies I think it's a very
underappreciated movie I don't know if
he even know it Bernie with Jack Black
Jack Black UCLA go Bruins he studied
acting right here in this building what
a good actor he is burning I think it's
just work of genius
I've hung on every frame so I'm not
blasting Richard Linklater but I do
think his problem is he may not
appreciate me saying this although he's
expansive enough that he actually might
see see with some value in it then he's
too close to it he worked on it for too
many years he wants to use all of this
stuff that he shot and that's a mistake
my brother-in-law a different
brother-in-law from the one I mentioned
earlier just came back from a vacating
the world he and his wife they retired
and traveling the world and God bless my
love oh I can't very much I love I love
them but one thing they do is they take
a lot of pictures with digital cameras
you know you can shoot you shoot I've
run out of film and when they and he's
he's a pretty good photographer and he
shoots a lot of you know Stanley always
sends a but he says the whole car you
know like what about they recently
they've just decided they're only gonna
send a hundred pictures oh nice just a
hundred I mean she's got six eight
hundred pictures I'll tell you the as a
photographer DeWitt Jones
who shot for the National Geographic a
lot of articles and the very interesting
statistic the typical National
Geographic article has 18 pictures in it
how many frames do they expose how many
pictures they actually take from which
they extract those 18 and he was we were
discussing this at the Maui conference
years ago prior to digital in other
words they were shooting film with
digital it's exponentially more so how
many what you guess the average number
of frames exposed film analog film
frames exposed from which 18 will be
taken for a National Geographic article
how many pictures do you think they
shoot 10,000 Wow for one article what
that means for writers is get ready to
throw stuff away it's again it's not
about building up and constructing it's
about throat taking down and throwing
away writers I like to tell writers you
know yet you need not merely to learn
that you have to throw away but you need
to learn this is what maturing is as a
writer loving to throw away you want to
see the best thing that's ever happened
to writing
I don't know how if we if we can get
this here it's a cat it's Jam that's a
computer keyboard and I'll just tell you
that if I could get it into the frame I
could point to this key it says de Leite
that's the best thing that ever happened
for writing and you have to learn that
when you highlight a bunch of stuff you
realize I don't need this this line of
dialogue I don't need this scene and you
highlight the whole thing and then you
hit delete in the whole scene vanishes
if you get a good feeling out of that
then your amateur writer it'll take
years and years to get to that most of
the time you're gonna be like well why
are you gonna feel that way about
because you took time to create that you
believed in it and now you're throwing
it away what about the stuff you're
writing now you're gonna how can you
create anything more if you know the
tomorrow you may throw this away yet
that's what you have to do and the truth
is tomorrow you will throw away probably
not all of it but just most of it and if
you do that eventually you'll have a
whole work you know you'll have old
screenplay
you